if I reached for hours as a hundred ton
fuel tank burned 15 special firefighting
Vehicles were sent by Azerbaijan to
extinguish The Blaze
people gathered to fill their tanks as
tens of thousands of ethnic Armenians
leave karabakh
Russian peacekeepers and the Red Cross
are evacuating critically wounded burn
victims
ill-equipped hospitals struggled with
the influx of hundreds of patients
several facilities including a medical
center run by the Russian peacekeeping
Mission were quickly overwhelmed
Aid has started to arrive and Medics are
calling for Urgent supplies it's urgent
that all these patients hundreds of
patients get as much Medical Care as
they can but it's also urgent that these
patients are moved to medical facilities
that are better are able to better care
for them
representatives of the azerbaijani
government say they're in contact with
the representatives of the Armenian
residents of karabakh the Red Cross is
being given access to treat the wounded
medical workers and supplies are being
flown in from Armenia and some patients
in critical condition are being taken
back
the azerbaijani government says it's
opened its airspace sent in medical help
and put hospitals around the karabakh
region on high alert but after years of
mistrust and fighting ethnic Armenians
aren't even ready to bring in their
critically wounded patients for
treatment into Azerbaijan
karabakh region
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera